just first touch on what we saw on
sunday night the lioness is doing so
well
it was incredible um you know they were
resilient they've been fantastic
throughout the whole tournament um even
the game against germany whereby they
had their backs to the wall at times but
they showed the right commitment
determination drive you know they were
they did the nation proud because of
course we all expect
when teams play well they win and you
know if they have their backs in the
wall they're going to lose particularly
against germany and it looks like that
stage
wants especially in german equalize but
they show so much passion and
determination to come through so yeah
they did really well i'm proud of them
yeah absolutely right and what do you
think it's going to do then for for the
women's game all of those sort of
naysayers now will have to just keep
strum wouldn't you say
what has to happen for the women's game
is not necessarily just when england
played because england played don't play
that often the club game is where it has
to improve so all these lionesses who
play for england and we know them where
they play for england most people don't
know what clubs they play for and
unfortunately when they play for their
clubs you have one two thousand people
turning up what has to happen is when
they go away and play for their clubs as
they will do every single week that is
when they need the support not just when
they play for england because of course
it's easy to be a fair weather fan when
we're in the world cup and we support
them but what about their bread and
butter day to day when they're at their
clubs that is when they really need the
support for the woman for the for the
women's football to really go to the
next level
and that's how you make sure that the
pay that these players get goes up as
well because if you get better gate
receipts you get more sponsors coming in
that's how the women are gonna get paid
better
well they're playing in front of two
thousand people when they play for their
clubs so how are they gonna get paid
better when they even have league two
teams who've got more than them who who
have bigger crowds so the sponsors are
gonna be interested if the public are
interested so it's okay for the public
now saying how much we're supporting
them because we all watch the the
european championship island and wembley
was full what about
in the coming months when they play for
their clubs
now you have to put your money where
your mouth is if you're a real football
fan
well just on that then i think you've
got a little bit of research john that
you've been doing on uh football fans
going to games and the way cost of
living is going to be affecting people
right tell us about that
it's not
perfect virgin media i've done the
research to show that nearly half of the
football fans would prefer to stay at
home and watch the game um not just
because it cost a living crisis but of
course you know there are benefits to
that whereby you know you can just
go to the loop whenever you want you can
sit and watch in the comfort of your own
home you can pause it uh to go and watch
uh to go to to to watch something else
so i think that increasingly we've seen
that you know people watching at home um
is becoming they're becoming much more
prevalent the vast majority of fans
don't go to football matches they watch
it at home and you know virgin media
have a package now which is the cheapest
package in the uk so you know as i said
a lot of people can't get to the games
not just because of the cost of living
crisis but because it's hard to get
tickets you know you may support a team
which is 500 miles away so increasingly
um we are now seeing people being at
home to watch the game so uh
long long may that continue because as i
said it's difficult for people in this
day and age now particularly for the
cost of living um crisis to be able to
afford to watch football matches live so
it's great to see that they'll still be
able to support their teams or even just
watch a game a lot of people may not
even support a club but they love
watching football and the access is
there
and of course other providers of premier
league football are available sky being
one as we know now let's talk a little
bit about the premier league season what
are you looking out for jonah i don't
know if you saw harland in the charity
shield the other day do you look like
the player that we're thinking he's
gonna be
well he's the player we think he's gonna
be he may not have scored at the weekend
and he may not have looked that player
then but of course you know you don't
just judge him from one game um you know
the quality he actually has so i'm sure
for manchester he'll do well nunez
scored first and lunes is similar
they've come for a big price tag they
probably changed the dynamic of both
teams because losing money means that
now we have a classic number nine center
forward who we have to adapt to he has
to adapt to us matches this into a
similar they never had a big number nine
center forward who will just get the
ball in the box that need to score ahead
of so they'll also have to adapt but i
think that those two teams once again
will be the two teams to look out for
chelsea will be strongest as well as
partner those two i think can push
liverpool and manchester city close but
i still can't sleep beyond liverpool or
manchester city
and uh my uh director romero is just
shouting about what about arsenal and
you also missed another north west club
as well there didn't you another one
that plays in red i can't remember the
name now
as i said look arsenal i think you know
jesus is a fantastic signing i think
that if you look at our tetter and after
winning that battle with the bumayang in
terms of who's going to be in charge who
who who rules the club and it's the
right thing to do the manager has to be
the the main man you saw arsenal improve
and also will improve once again they've
still got a young improving side so i'm
not going to say they're going to
challenge for a top two but they'll
challenge for third or fourth um so as i
say you've got arsenal tottenham chelsea
unknown quantitative man united because
once again the harmony is not right the
disunity the problems that they're
actually having with ronaldo is he
saying is he going that's not a good
situation to go into but um it's going
to be an exciting season